um so i'm an economist and i've
was very happy to see over the past 40
years the
incredible progress of women in the
labor market
and that progress was largely largely
fueled by women's increased
participation in iu education
in most oec d countries
young women outnumber manned in iu
education three to two
so here in this graph we see that in
canada and in the united states up to
the late 1980s there were more young men
in iu education
than young women but then
instead of simply catching up
to men
women began to overtake man and it is
this overtaking story that is the puzzle
perhaps it's the case that
after many decades of having having
difficulty in school school the school
environment responded a little better
to a woman's need
but
was it the case that now
boys who had long struggled with reading
in school were they really more into
more difficulty
is it
as
the press
most often writes about it
that boys are falling behind not doing
as well than before
or are they actually
left behind as girls really forge ahead
and
adopt identities of career women
where where has boys are not sure what
to do
so in order to try to address this issue
we wanted to take the long view look
over many decades
we also wanted to focus on high school
kids because to get into university you
need to have good grades in school
so
we looked at 35 years of the monitoring
the future data which are u.s
data and so from 1975 to 2010 here we
see that on average girls have long had
better uh grade point average and boys
about 2.2 points on the four-point scale
so this is not so much just the
difference between a b-minus and a b
however what has changed over time
is that there's been a disaffection with
grading to the curve that we can see in
these instagram these histograms show
the percentage of girls at the top and
the boys at the bottom who are in the
different categories and what we see
here is that in the 2000 girls were more
likely most often likely to get an a
and boys well there was some increase
but not as much
so if we could focus simply on the a's
we see that in the 1990s about 10
percent of girls were getting a's
and that percentage had gone to about 20
in the 2000
so girls were really becoming becoming
really high achievers
boys were not falling behind there was
really an increase in their uh good
grades but they were left behind uh by
girls
so we wanted to try to find out
what were
some factors that may
be motivating or maybe
accounting for that change
and so one of the things we kind of
looked at were uh the educational
expectation or aspirations of these
young people here the high school
seniors
and when we look at uh the students who
say they will they say they will
definitively want to attend grad school
here we see a tremendous raise among
girls
wanting to attend graduate school
about a quarter of girls in the 2000s
say that they want to attend grad school
so this is very impressive
and
i also want to say when we look
at people or young people who say that
they definitely want to go to college
we find that even among 8th graders we
see this gender ratio this 55-45 gender
ratio
uh is uh the dash line here the green
dash line and beginning in eighth grade
girls have this idea of what they want
to do
but then
when you think about it a quarter of
girls wanted to go to grad school do
they
do they know what's involved is there a
sense that they want to achieve what do
they want to achieve from that
so
we looked at the change in vocational
that is what do these people expect they
will be doing when they will be age 30.
and here we found some clues to our
puzzle we found that there had been a
tremendous change over time and that
indeed in the 2000s there were more than
a quarter of girls who wanted to be
professionals with a doctoral degree or
equivalent lawyers and so on or in that
categories
and that this
was a big change over time whereas among
boys the boys who had these change in
aspirations were really not as large
so where was this coming from
interestingly it was coming from a very
important decrease in the number of
girls who aspired to be office workers
in the 1980s one in five girls wanted to
be a secretary or an office worker
and then in the
that was 1 in 40. that's a tremendous
change that makes a lot of sense from a
labor economy's point of view because
essentially uh these the demand for
these occupation has declined
tremendously over time with the
increases in computers in the office and
so on
over that period of time there was also
some decline in the expectations of boys
wanting to work in the what we could
call middle skill occupation
craftsmen and so on but not to the same
extent
so
then we did a more detailed analysis to
try to compare
this
these change in plans for the future to
other factors that had also changed over
time there there was a student behavior
the family environment and work during
school over that 35 years period
there had been changes on gender
differences and what we found is that
the idea of plan for the future was the
overwhelming factor that was explaining
for example there is an excess a six
percentage point in the number of
girls who are earning a's and about a
third of that was actually accounted by
the gender differences in these plan for
the future
and also importantly
this was also happening among our 8th
graders
so our 8th graders here we had better
measures of student behavior which
included misbehavior having been sent to
the office the the the year prior and so
on
and so here sure enough uh we could
explain some of the excess girl in da's
with
these plans for the future
at about the same the same percentage
but some part of the d the excess of
boys in the c's and the d's was also
explained by uh student misbehavior so
um these were
very interesting findings that we're
going to probe
by going at
lower level schools and this was done
with
observational data
as economists when we want to take the
long view we go to observational data
but i want to say that these findings
have been incorporated in some
experimental research this one in
particular conducted by srdc
where they had some experimental
intervention trying to
improve access to post-secondary
education and they did find much larger
differences much larger impact of their
intervention for boys and for girls
essentially the girls were already on
track
so the big question
why should we care about this new gender
imbalance in higher education
it shouldn't be as we say in french
just all day shows a proper reversal of
roles
um
well let's adopt different perspective
as we're
now doing
in the context of cfar
let's think of the economist the
economists will care about the
misallocation of resources that could be
due to misinformation perhaps the young
boys are
unaware of the wages and employment
opportunity in the mid-scale occupations
perhaps the young women are unaware of
the high demand of the professions that
they want to embrace
so that could create some skill mismatch
let's now think about a demographer the
demographer may be
concerned about marriage markets
with
less
men getting college education
more college educated women will marry
men with lower level of education
this might leave
less educated women unmarried and
raising families in more difficult
circumstances
now the sociologists may care about the
change in the balance of power in the
family and so this is uh from the
canadian data actually
uh and
from the work of marianne bertrand
cooper where she shows that
when the wife
shares of total family income exceeds
one half there is an increased risk of
divorce
so really kind of interesting um
issues here uh will wives want to
curtail their hours in the labor market
to reduce their hours and their um
avoid overtaking their husband's earning
all kinds of very interesting questions
and finally for the parents
the parents may be concerned that their
girls are going to be perhaps stretched
out between the demands of the career
and the demand of the family the parents
of boys may be concerned about
boys spending too much time playing
video games and so on as the male
picture suggests whereas they would
like to see their boy becoming
businessmen and so on so these are all a
very important question and especially i
think the questions of the role of video
gaming is one that
i will want to address
in future research
however all of this is not uh so dire
because when we look at happiness all
things considered here it's from a 2.3
point scale we see that over time
basically the gender gap in happiness
has reverse and the boys are relatively
more happy
than the girls
so i will conclude with this thank you
very much
you